part two let's just refresh our memory
and see what we needed to find
part two determine the interval that the
particle moves through and the maximum
speed of the particle okay now there's a
few ways to go about this let's do
maximum speed first because i actually
think it's most uh straightforward right
how do i find maximum speed well i can
actually use something directly from
part one that will enable me to find
maximum speed very very quickly i can
say
when is maximum speed happening and the
answer is maximum speed happens
as you pass by the center of motion
right because you've been sort of
accelerated back toward the the center
of motion and then as you pass the
center of motion you are
no acceleration you're not speeding up
you're not slowing down you can't get
any faster than that and at that exact
moment you're not being slowed down so
that's where maximum speed occurs in the
center of motion but from part one i
know where the center of motion is it's
going to be as stated here at x equals 2
because that's what shift has been
introduced so i can say maximum speed
occurs
at the center of motion which is x
equals 2.
the reason why that's useful is because
you can go back to the very first
expression that we were given here or
equation i should say which is the
velocity in terms of the displacement so
i can just put x equals two into here do
a straight substitution and that will
give me a result that will help me get
speed so let's go ahead and do that
x equals 2. when i substitute that into
the v squared equation you can see
there's going to be a 9 out the front
and then i've got 5 plus 4 times 2 is 8.
2 squared is 4. when i have a look at
this this is 13 take away 4 is 9. so i'm
getting v squared equals 9 times 9 which
is 81.
from this the reason why i've got a v
squared of course by the way is that
velocity
has direction built into it right so it
can be either positive or negative so
strictly speaking at x equals 2 which is
the center of motion am i going in the
positive direction or the negative
direction and the answer is i could be
going in either so that's why this is
ambiguity built into the question or
into the equation i should say
however what we need to remember and
this is again a key point that some
students struggle with velocity is a
vector so it mines which direction you
are in right but we are not asked for
velocity or maximum velocity we asked
for maximum speed and speed is a scalar
i think this is coincidental this is
kind of convenient that it alliterates
right velocity is a vector speed is a
scalar so therefore i can say
i can just not worry about which
direction it's going in if i take the
square root of both sides that gives me
the absolute value on the left hand side
and i just get the positive square root
here of 81 which is 9. so i'm done
that's the
maximum speed that i'm after
i should tie this up in a neat bow by
providing units as well because the
question did give that to me maximum
speed
is 9 meters per second
remembering back to the questions units
so that was only half of part 2 the
other half was to know the range of
motion determine the interval that the
particle moves through so how do i do
that
well what i can use i mean there's a
couple of ways i should do this i could
do this by the way and i'll actually
show you two but the most
straightforward way to do it is kind of
pulling the same trick that i just did
here with working out maximum speed
where does maximum speed occur answer at
the center of motion
where does
where is the interval of motion defined
by and the answer is where you're kind
of stopping right if you know where
you're stationary your extremities of
motion
then you can just say well wherever
those x values are that is the interval
that you move through so i can say
at the extremities the particle is
stationary in fact i think it's so
important to actually say that so i'm
going to i'm going to write here at the
extremities
this is part of my reasoning
the particle is stationary in other
words v
is equal to 0. and i again can go back
to the original equation provided to me
and just
solve that in fact i can even go less
than solving if i say well the v squared
equation is up here
there it is right there i can say
this thing here
is going to be equal to
the velocity which is 0 squared right so
i can say i e i'm dividing through by 9
of course doesn't change anything and
while i'm dividing 3 by nine you know
what let's divide through by minus nine
because that'll change this um this
negative that's in front of the x
squared it'll change into a harmonic uh
quadratic so it's just gonna have a
leading coefficient of one so here i go
dividing three by minus nine it gives me
an x squared minus 4x minus 5 equals 0.
the factorization here is not too
complicated it's going to be x minus 5 x
plus 1
equals 0. so this tells me like the
solution of this is x equals negative
one or five and that doesn't actually
answer the question i need to know the
range of motion so i just need to say
that it's between x equals negative one
and x equals five so therefore
range of motion
is or the interval um they're saying the
same thing is negative one
two
five
done i suppose you could use in interval
notation here if you wanted okay
now i did promise there was one other
way that i thought made sense to do this
i don't like it as much and the way that
i just showed you was probably the least
error prone and most likely to succeed
but you know many approaches to this and
one of the great things about simple
harmonic motion is that you can use some
of the forms of on the different
equations that come out of simple
harmonic motion to read off the
attributes of the particular motion or
the particular particle and how it moves
that you're interested in right so if i
just go back to the original equation
which was v squared equals 9 outside of
5 plus 4x minus x squared
some of you may remember that i can do
some factorizing and some completing the
square here
to make obvious what's going on here
with the motion without actually doing
uh this particular having this knowledge
here that the at the extremity of the
particle is stationary right so what i
can do here is inside the brackets i'm
going to
break apart the five into
two different numbers that allow me to
complete the square because there should
be a square
sort of a quadratic coming out of this
that's going to help me read off the
center of motion and therefore
and also the amplitude of motion right
so if you have a think about this right
4x minus x squared what do i need to add
or subtract to that in order to complete
the square and the answer is if i put
this in a more helpful order right
minus x squared plus 4x in order to
complete the square here you're halving
and squaring this middle coefficient
right this is the the b and the ax
squared plus bx plus c right so when you
hover and square it you get four but
don't forget this is actually going to
be a minus four not a plus four because
this whole quadratic is actually
negative right so if i had a positive x
squared it'd be x squared minus 4x
possible
but here i'm going to match the sign out
the front
now there's a minus 4 there it started
with a 5. so how is this going to
balance out the answer is with a 9. can
you see there that this
5 i can break it apart into that 9 and
that whoopsie daisy
that minus 4 9 minus 4 last i checked is
equal to 5 but the reason why this is
useful is that now i can do that
factorization and complete the square
there in in the middle so i can go 9
outside of i'm going to write that next
9 as 3 squared take away and then let's
just be careful here this is going to be
x plus
x minus 2 rather all squared because in
fact once i take this minus sign out
that becomes a minus 4x you can see why
this is not the ideal method there's a
lot of minus signs and a lot of actual
algebraic manipulation that is
unnecessary you can see it was a lot
easier to do up here so just adding that
cognitive load is just an extra
confusion factor
so once you have
done that you can see here
this 3 here is actually going to be the
amplitude if you didn't remember that
form that's me reminding it reminding
you of it and this here that x equals 2
is the center of motion that we
identified back in part 1. so from that
i can say
therefore that interval is going to be
it's going to be 2 minus 3
and it's going to be 2 plus 3. you can
see there there's the center of motion
appearing there twice and then you can
go in the negative direction 3 and in
the positive direction 3 because of that
amplitude there and hopefully it is
pretty straightforward to see that that
gives you the original result
not ideal i think it you're sort of
asking to confuse yourself but this this
method is valid so it works totally fine